nora che dovete vedere il menu ti prego
non è solo per la musica ma e per tutto
ok facciamo questo è cosa volevi fare se
non questo certo facciamo quello bello
fare quello che ha detto lei sono ha
quindi ios quindi io sono la tipa non ho
capito ma eravamo qua in 261 riprendeva
ero io
e poi c'era la tipa io sono la tipa o
quello che riprendeva vediamo a
giudicare dalla forma della mia testa
sono il tipo dalla forma dell'ombra non
si capisce una sega di quello che c'è
scritto l'ho trovata che culo tra tutte
le cose ho trovato lingua se vi rendete
conto che culo ho cliccato su opzioni a
caso sistema inglese che culo c'erano un
miliardo di cose ho cliccato su quella
giusta mamma mia
non so con che criterio è riprendiamo
lavorava rimasti adesso capirmi cabria
era inconcepibile
no ragazzi culo c'è veramente c'erano un
miliardo di opzioni non so come ho fatto
a peccare lingua subito pazzesca sta
roba bene dai
storani dietro non ho capito ma sotto la
miniera giusto di cuocere la cosa però
malconci si abbassa hicks o prima non me
lo ha neanche detto ips perché hicks
inglese e in cinese si dice in un altro
modo probabilmente va bè bello però mai
più volte ed una sorella morta ieri
porco demonio makita chiesto niente
ma chi ti ha chiesto niente ma te lo
meriti la te lo meriti ma che è stata la
tip inglobasse nel cuore ce l'ha non ho
capito ma non ho capito io ho perso nel
fulvio perso tutto il controller a che
la di da ho perso ottimo sei tranquillo
quindi lei era la mia ragazza si chiama
cai cei cioè perché mi ha detto mi ha
fatto una smorfietta d'amore quindi è
morta rt run a si può correre wow
la devo trovare devo trovare la mia
ragazza bellissimo questo gioco e
speriamo sia realistico un giorno allora
grazie
l'importante che che ti stia bene qui io
sono il tizio che riprendeva con la
videocamera che non ce lo più tra
l'altro perché una videocamera
bellissima comunque sono contento del
fatto che andiamo però tra tutti i posti
dove volete andare gli slot che gli da
chi è l'altro dentro eccola arrosti chi
roba scritta in cinese non ci voglio
dire altro ko per adesso ci siamo le
temps
credo che la mia ragazza si è andata di
qua perché quella porta chiusa prima
prevede
no mi [ __ ] le mele che ciò fame
intanto questo è il riso buonissimo cioè
la salsa teri a chi che la butto
direttamente sorriso mi fa mi piace che
non ha un senso tutto questo
allora costa e musiche questo martin
garics velo buco po il pallone questo
non è tanto farvi di freno speriamo che
youtube non se ne accorgano se non li
guardo non riguardo io non devo parlare
per forza che deve seminare bene
per me la faccio qua
sarà spegne st radio
ok
ciao porca put lui la madonna
[Musica]
quella voleva mia ragazza corri si può
non si può correre
starei già correndo prete mi ha preso
madonna che il gioco ansiolitico
incredibile non ho mai giocato una roba
del genere in tutta la mia vita ragazzi
lo sto scherzando
cioè veramente fatto bene ma fatto però
mette un attimo out di no vabbè altro
ancora peggio madonna che brutto fatto
benissimo e io vorrei correre solo
titolare è molto più veloce di me
la donna non è che era è un correrà
lenti vorrei nasconda amico dentro ma mi
ha visto ne ha visto che vi sono
scontento
[Musica]
dove sarà mai il tuo ragazzo dove sarà
mai dove sarà comunque sono sempre state
le mie ex contavano le loro cose quindi
più o meno aichen relates to this dal
senno di poi mi sembra una roba full of
jobs che ha visto che stiamo giocando da
un minuto e già è pieno di roba ci sono
giochi non ha visto ok stavo dicendo ci
sono giochi horror che prima che ci sia
anche solo un jobs che magari passano
già due episodi c'è questo cane ha fatti
già mille cioè non ho trovato un senso a
tutto questo però va bene mettiamo qua
ho capito cosa vuole che cosa vuoi
allora devo chiudere kg a porta prossima
volta ricordiamo quando usate le
maniglie chiudete la porta ma questo è
importante la porta è chiuso col cristo
l'ho trovato anche qua qua qua sollevo
de blanck spa sono quelle blacks 20 20
20 di forza di farle eccola lovè chiude
genere i tornei
è bello store ed a tutti i ragazzi e
benvenuti in un loro video sullo yoga
come rilassarsi dove insegnava vj fa vj
si butta nei tombini per rilassarsi
fatelo anche voi non scherzavano l'ho
fatto teoricamente teoricamente rondon
dottor scotti
c'è un telefono di softball io non ho io
comunque ragazzi non ho mai giocato un
gioco così io lo voglio di mai mai
guarda guarda te in asia nella mia vita
io non ho mai giocato nord questa è la
prima volta mi sto veramente cagando
nelle mutande c'è chi giuro è fatto da
dio ma io non ho mai vista una roba del
genere pensavo mai potesse essere fatto
cosi bene
katsav a sua scuola la lampadina doctor
scoppi rondò the game che suona suo
campanello ma sfrutta qualcuno nella
botola lo so io non le ha sfruttate
nessuno
è la madonna porca vacca pronto pizza
trova la casa della donna vecchia barene
troviamo a casa la casa della donna
vecchia vi sembra giusto perché quando
uno prende due o tre infarti chiama la
vecchia siamo a posto
gran gioco un po ovunque andiamo avanti
e nonostante tutto sto casino vediamo se
riesco a trovare la vecchia a vecchia
belli con quei poster visto che non c'è
una persona mancato il caricamento
dovremmo essere in una parte della città
non lo so non c'è nessuno cioè della
città di da parte di vicoli sono in
mezzo è un mega condominio tutto questo
non è possibile luce un carissimo amico
lo più le pinze per tagliare i lucchetti
delle cose
eccolo qua perfetto come trovare una
scusa ma dopo un secondo ho io sto
passato nelle fogne teoricamente non
dovrebbe più esserci la mia ti fa la mia
ex
credo che adesso si siano lasciati non
ne sono sicuro però vorrei chiedergli
ero con sicurezza
secondo me se usa il 66 di dell'iphone
non si sblocca l'iphone però c'è un
armadio chi è veramente orribile perché
vuol dire che arriverà qualcuno tra 3 2
1 mentre ero e mentre ero accovacciato
tutto questo non volevo sbirciati sotto
la gonna e che non so qual è il tasto
per alzarmi a che l'ho trovato comunque
non riesco a capire come faccio a
trovarvi di 4 secondi c'è incredibile
fatto tu non hai sentito niente
un marona corrie cordice denunciò voglia
di aspettare corri corri perfetto la
scarpa ho mica se non ti acquistò da chi
sfondo a pedate madonna guarda ci manca
solo quello ragazzi basta che anzi a
farmi andare dove sta a casa questa
vecchia maronna lugano come si come si
passa in cui ci sono oggetti uno sopra
l'altro si capisce niente chiudi la
porta
cosa fare qua no non so veramente
capendo cosa devo fare
ok c'era una botola non l'ha vista sono
un pessimo osservatori ragazzi non so
stessa nottata sta cosa posso andare
tranquillo avanti o migliori sfruttare
il demonio travestito la doraemon capite
ragazzi questo era come si chiama starò
paranormal la paragona a hong kong è
teoricamente hk pensiamo ancora gioco
cinese però bello ma bello forte ci
vediamo prossimo episodio che non
continuerà sabato al bellissimo lo conti
però sicuro schiacciate mi piace se vi è
piaciuto iscritte camera campanellina
prima giornata sui video che escono
problema ritenendo questo giuro da rete
da una vita e non provo un horror così
bellissimo meglio di quello thailandese
dell'altra volta però i signori come
sempre ci vediamo al prossimo video e
ragazzi
[Musica]